und es ist sehr knusprig braun unter
teils zu fliegen das ist nicht in höhe
gebracht wurde diese feder lecker oder
auch so einfach wenn man mal gäste
hatten
bekundet
[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute bewusst
access zu beginnen oder zum anfang
meiner ramadan reihe ein fingerfood das
war bis jetzt jedes jahr so dass immer
zu beginn halt irgendwie sowas mega
leckeres für nebenbei neben der suppe
oder so was ich euch so inspiration
gegeben habe in den letzten jahren war
es halt ganz viel dieses panierte billig
diese runden zigarette oder man sagt
glaube ich auch also sie gar abriss
veralteter das heißt sie gar in berlin
aber wir haben auch christian buric
gehabt es waren diese dreiecke also
schaut euch die ganze videos gerne mal
an heute machen wir
mozzarellas ticks auf die orientalische
art und dafür brauchen wir ganz wenige
zutaten es ist ein ganz einfaches rezept
ich mache es auch wieder gerne im ofen
wie auch in den letzten jahren auch ich
mag das nicht wenn es um so frittiert
ist und ich würde sagen ich leg direkt
mal los wir brauchen uns zu allererst
hier so eine art trinke wo wir das
besser rein tun und dafür nehme ich ja
ich habe jetzt zwar hier zwei eier aber
bewahrt euch ein eigelb später zum
bestreichen noch auf also schlag des der
schüssel und dann wie gesagt dass eine
einfach nur aufbewahren und dann kommt
in die schüssel noch öl da könnt ihr
sonnenblumen oder rapsöl nehmen und
etwas milch
[Musik]
jetzt geht es weiter mit dem yoga teig
ich hatte euch bei meinem chris perry
kretz app habe denke ich krieg schon in
der sogar aber wie man habe ich euch da
diesen jederzeit das ist das ist der
frühlingsrollen teig ist richtig typisch
asiatisch den brauchen wir nicht geld
kommt doch aus dem tiefkühler wir
brauchen diesen typisch türkischen
joschka teig da gibt es auch
verschiedene varianten und wir brauchen
da dem dreieckigen which can you heißt
dreieck auch tödlich so und da mal mit
zu folgen
übrigens auch sehr schnell daher
entweder zügig arbeiten oder immer
wieder in die packung leben oder ein
tuch darüber legen und dann machen wir
jetzt folgendes das ist mit so ein
bisschen zu groß und ich hätte gerne so
kleine häppchen und daher habe ich das
immer und dann kommt quasi unsere
füllung drauf aber ich werde zum
beispiel erst mal als halbieren um euch
das zu zeigen denn wir werden auch die
lüfterblätter die ja an sich schon super
trocken sind und manchmal reist doch
einst so wie hier das ist aber nicht
schlimm das kriegsbeil im interview mit
und das ist ganz wichtig dass man den
jetzt nochmal mit dieser tränke
bestreicht da habe ich jetzt hier mein
pinsel halbiere ich das bestreitet und
dann kommt schon unsere füllung 1
[Musik]
so für die mozzarella sticks brauchen
wir natürlich mozzarella und ich habe
auch noch kauder dazu genommen den haben
sie zu frisch gerieben bei mozzarella
ist es ja so dass der eigentlich relativ
geschmacksneutral ist deswegen kommt
weiß und wetter dazu und hier ist ja
schon recht salzig deswegen reicht das
eigentlich wenn ich wirklich ein monster
wir müssen so ein bisschen pfeffer drauf
ein bisschen verrückt vermengen und dann
geben wir hier auf das vorbereitete yoga
blatt in die mitte immer etwas
mozzarella und immer noch ein bisschen
käse nicht zu viel ich weise diese ist
mega und so aber nicht dass das ding ja
den seiten ausläuft und dann wollen wir
das einfach nur noch ein
[Musik]
so ich habe jetzt alles schön aufgerollt
und einmal noch mal in diese mischung
betont dass es einfach wichtig dass es
überhaupt nicht trocken wird es wird
gleich natürlich nach dem backen auf
jeden fall ein wenig knusprig aber wir
müssen halt vorher das ganze noch mal
reingucken damit wie eben genau das
perfekte ergebnis bekommen und für die
optik nehme ich jetzt hier noch das
eigelb kommt jetzt ein bisschen nämlich
mit dazu dann wird das volk wählt und
dann bestreite ich jetzt einfach nur
noch die mozzarella sticks und dann
kommt dann auch wenn ihr mögt muss jetzt
aber nicht sagen ich bin zwar optisch
schöner könnte da noch die sahne
obendrauf streuen und das ganze backofen
habe ich vorgeheizt auf 190 grad obern
unterhält sondern dürfen sie einfach nur
goldbraun werden
[Musik]
so will probieren jetzt natürlich noch
weil diese videos sind vorgedreht also
noch mal drei wochen dazu das video
anzugucken
wir gucken uns nicht selber heute
anderen linien sind dann fast aber jetzt
können wir einfach ich habe für die
zukunft die banken für die zukünftigen
videos würde ich aber auch den test sind
amateurhaft aufnehmen dem handy oder so
flächenbedarf nicht wählen
seine expertise des gehört leute gibt
schon heute die akademische nötigen ja
klar also hierzu es ist mir ein bisschen
was ausgelaufen eigentlich möchte ist
nichts verschleiern der käse ist ein
bisschen ausgelaugt sind übertrieb es
ist noch viel drin ich habe wirklich es
kommt einem so vor als wäre das nix
vormachen wir haben dann ist es doch
viel aber es ist ja gar nicht schlimm
und euch ist es sehr knusprig braun
totalstopp dass ich ihm viel gebracht
wurde ich mache das war auch im öl
gebraten oder fühlt man sich schlecht
dabei ja ich finde es auch machen sich
schon da kann es mal ran hier wandert
man sieht man ihr an
dass sie schon lecker aus also ich bin
das ist schon so perfekte beilage zu
suppe doch mal was denn ich musste ja
immer geht das video habe ich mir auch
gedacht wirklich auslaufen oder dann
dachtest du nie wenn es rauskommt soll
es so einfarbig sein so ist die würfel
stimmt meine gedanken begriff super mega
typisch zu suppe hat man immer ein
bisschen fingerfood oder auch so einfach
wenn man mal gäste hat da hat also ich
könnte jetzt noch noch ganz er tagsüber
also auf jeden fall wünsche euch viel
spaß und nachmachen ich verabschiede
mich an der show und kies die beste
die kinder mit dieser beste und krach
machen
also bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]